people ask if it's glued if there's
steel rods a lot of people really don't
understand that it's just balanced these
mind-bending rock formations are held
together with nothing but gravity rock
balancing our predates the Bible and can
be found across the globe Michael grab
is one of the best balances around and
his creations have turned him into an
internet phenomenon the structure that
probably got me noticed first
internationally was kind of this orb
structure that I made and it's just
hundreds of little rocks kind of
balanced on a really tiny one at the
bottom one of my core drives is to make
the formation as impossible as possible
or to challenge my own skill and kind of
one-up myself each time a lot of
reactions to my process while I'm
building is like oh no that's impossible
they'll never happen especially when I
try to take a huge rock and put it on a
tip and then people are just kind of
mind blown when I actually let go anyone
can make rock piles but Michael has
spent the last 12 years perfecting the
art of balance
I started balancing in about 2008 here
in Boulder Colorado and Boulder Creek
yeah I just fell in love with it and
started doing it every day and it kind
of took over my life so I ended up
quitting my job and doing it full-time
there aren't many people out there who
can call themselves professional rock
balancers but these fragile creations
take a lot of practice I pretty much go
out on a daily basis if the weather's
nice mainly the wind is what I consider
bad weather so if it's snowing or
raining I usually go out anyway and
that's just part of the beauty of the
art form is just getting out in the
elements it took Michael over a decade
to get to this level a lot of his
creations would take multiple attempts
to get quite
each sculpture is different but every
time Michael builds he follows the same
process the first thing he must do is
find a location to create the stack I've
built several structures here over the
years I just like it because I like the
texture of the rock and the way the
water flows over the rock to create
towers that look like they're defying
gravity takes a lot of time so Michael
needs to make himself comfortable once I
decide where I want to build I need to
make kind of a temporary stone chair
like so and I'm just trying to make a
very stable surface to plant my
bodyweight on and one that's kind of
level once he's got a comfy seat it's
time to choose his tools for balancing I
want the rocks to be completely clean so
either I'll grab them from an area
that's not so mossy or just kind of
loose bare rocks and I'm looking for
different textures and surfaces like
this kind of has a cup on the bottom
it's really important to find rocks that
have three points of contact in between
these three points is the center of
gravity it works exactly the same as a
camera tripod you just have to Center
the mass so I kind of matched that up
with my big base Boulder here and get it
in a position that is completely stable
in between the contacts so all the
weight is going to be channel the rate
to this point he always works backwards
picking the final rock first the bigger
the top rock the more impossible the
structure will look when he lets go this
is the rock I've designated as my top
rock just because I like the shape of it
and it has a nice kind of rounded point
down at the bottom here so I basically
want to balance it in this orientation
as Michael starts to build he has to
make sure that the structure has a solid
foundation has to be the most stable at
the bottom because any kind of
vibrations will magnify as they come up
the structure with a traditional rock
the build becomes more challenging the
weight increases and rocks could fall on
Michael at any time but actually takes
quite a bit of physical strength to get
this one balanced safely they have to
hold this one with this hand with all
this weight so it's like really wanting
to fall that way the rocks are heavy so
any collapses could lead to broken
fingers so yeah this whole art form is
definitely not for the faint of heart
you just kind of go all in or else you
might get injured once all of the rocks
below are aligned the final piece of the
puzzle is also the most risky the top
rock as I'm building up the core of the
structure I'm kind of estimating this
final weight and position of the top
rock and so once it actually gets up
there then it's like the actual weight
that I'm working with and so sometimes
my adjustments that I've been making the
whole time will be a little bit off
they're pretty close right now like it's
barely balanced
but I'm gonna get out of here because
you got to do that carefully also
because they're so finally poised a
tower like this may not last very long
the structures will last anywhere from a
few seconds to a few days at the end of
every build Michael likes to test the
integrity of the tower by splashing it
with water final process I usually do is
splash it with water and if it can
survive through this then it's worthy to
be photographed this also gives it an
amazing ice sculpture effect if left
overnight in the cold colder air part of
this whole rock balancing thing is
actually getting into nature and
experiencing it firsthand like turning
over rocks and seeing what's on these
things and learning about the life
that's around in a bit to Leave No Trace
Michael destroys one of his structures
after photographing them I like to
document as much of the creation as
possible so that includes the build
process that includes the life of the
creation as long as it's standing and
also the collapse and ideally a natural
collapse due to wind or something like
that but even still if wind doesn't blow
it over and I'm done with all my
documentation then I'll just knock it
over myself
you